for months now our lives have been on
hold when the call came in March we
pressed pause on many of the things that
brighten our lives meals with friends
trips to the cinema or theater we had to
close out gyms and swimming pools
canceled our holidays and postponed some
of our favorite events but as we've made
huge progress against this disease we've
gradually seen the things we love
returned and today I'm very pleased to
announce that we can go a little bit
further as of this weekend our artists
musicians and dancers can start
performing live outside to outdoor
audiences we'll also have the resumption
of recreational sport followed later by
the reopening of our gyms swimming pools
and leisure centers normal life is
slowly returning this is an important
milestone for our performing artists who
have been waiting patiently in the wings
since March of course we won't see
crowds flooding into their venues but
from the 11th of July our theatres
operas dance and music shows can start
putting on outdoor performances to
socially distant audiences that means
theatre goers can experience a live play
for the first time and in months and
places like the stunning minyak theater
in Cornwall and music lovers can attend
blind born this summer we are taking
various measures to make these places
safe as they reopen venue capacity will
be reduced and organizations encouraged
to move to electronic ticketing to help
test and trace but our performing
artists deserve an audience and now they
will be getting one and while those
outdoor performances get under way we'll
be working with public health experts to
carefully pilot a number of indoor
performances from the London Symphony
Orchestra Edison Luke's to Buckland's to
work out how we can confidently usher
socially distance audiences indoors as
soon as possible at the same time we're
funding scientific studies to help us
understand and mitigate some specific
public health risks like the impact of
singing wind and brass instruments on
transmitter
the more we know about the coronavirus
in every setting the safer we will be
we're also taking steps through the
planning system to protect theaters and
venues from demolition or change of use
and of course all of this comes on top
of the unprecedented 1.5 7 billion pound
package of emergency support to help
arts heritage and cultural institutions
whether the kovetz storm but of course
we want to see all of our venues open as
soon as it's safe to do so and today's
announcement brings us a further step
closer towards that reality now having
allowed hairdressers to reopen
beauticians tattooist sparse tanning
salons and other close contact services
can now do the same I'm pleased to say
from Monday of course that will be
subject to some restrictions on
particularly high risk services as I've
seen for myself at the Royal Academy
this morning the National Gallery and as
we'll see shortly from the National
Museums Liverpool our cultural
institutions are beginning also to
welcome back visitors and as these
places begin to reopen their doors I'm
really urging people to get out there
and to play their part buy the tickets
for outdoor plays and music recitals get
to your local gallery and support your
local businesses and we've seen in
recent weeks how our landlords waiters
and shop assistants have welcomed
customers back with open arms whilst
doing so much to keep their community
safe it's time to give other businesses
those same opportunities and the
Chancellor this week set out a bumper
package of tourism and hospitality tax
breaks to get these industries firing on
all cylinders once more and protect the
millions of people who work for them
that means a VAT cut on everything from
tickets to shows theaters amusement
parks museums and zoos lower costs for
hotels Inns caravans and campsites and
vouchers for food and non-alcoholic
drinks and I'm urging British people to
make the most of this summer safely we
need them to support the places that we
all love
and today there is good news for our
nation's fitness as we all know exercise
is incredibly important for both
physical and mental health even at the
height of the lockdown it was considered
an essential activity with countless
people hitting their pots for their
daily run or transforming their living
rooms into temporary gyms and from this
weekend onwards millions of people will
be able to rejoin their local sports
teams as soon as their organizations
publish approved guidance recreational
cricket is back on this weekend
five-a-side football basketball hockey
and countless other sports will follow
shortly after and from this Saturday
they'll also be able to enjoy outdoor
pools and water parks and from Saturday
the 25th people will no longer have to
work out in their park or on their
living room floor they'll be able to get
back into their gyms their indoor
swimming pools their leisure centers and
jump on that spin bike or treadmill for
the first time in months now we've made
a number of positive visits to gyms in
recent weeks and of course we'd hope to
do this sooner but we really do have to
face this properly we will be giving
gyms the certainty clarity and time they
need to reopen safely so that the
maximum number can open their doors in
just a two weeks time and again we've
worked intensively with both
professional bodies and the experts to
get us to this point and facilities
we'll have to take a number of measures
to protect their communities that
includes for example using time booking
systems to limit the number of people
using the facility at any one time
reduce class sizes equipment will be
spaced out and there will be enhanced
cleaning throughout as always the public
will need to do their bit and follow the
guidance sensibly and safely all of
these measures we are taking are
conditional and they are reversible and
we will not hesitate to impose lock
downs where there are local spikes as we
saw unless the where things remain
closed and of course in any other place
when that is necessary but the return of
gyms and recreational sport is a vital
part
battle against coronavirus we need to
get the nation match fit to defeat this
disease and our fight began with a
collective effort and I really hope it
will end with one at the beginning we
all stayed at home to protect the NHS
and save lives
now the British public has a new part to
play it's time to eat out to help out to
enjoy the arts to help out and to work
out to help out it's over to all of you
to help the country recover safely